.
In den USA hat Susan ihren Vater
nach über 20 Jahren wieder getroffen.
Die Reise war intensiv -
und geht schon bald zu Ende.
Ich habe ihn besser kennengelernt.
Und ich habe viel erfahren,
wie er eigentlich ist.
Simas Reise in den Iran
wurde abgesagt.
Für die Familie ist es mega schlimm,
dass wir nicht kommen.
Sie haben alles vorbereitet.
Es fehlen immer noch Bewilligungen.
Kann Sima ihre fremde Heimat
trotzdem noch kennenlernen?
Und Yancey reist
mit seiner Frau Janine
das erste Mal
in sein Heimatland China.
Das ist quasi
der Moment der Ruhe vor dem Sturm.
Wir werden sehr viel Verwandtschaft
in China sehen.
Ich lasse mich überraschen,
was dann kommen wird.
Das ist eine Reise
zurück zu den Wurzeln,
die Reise in meine fremde Heimat.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Beschwingte Gitarrenklänge *
Am Hallwilersee im Kanton Aargau.
Das sind Yancey und seine Frau Janine
mit ihrem Töchterchen Alicia.
Morgen geht es los mit der Reise
in die fremde Heimat China.
Yancey wuchs mit seinen
chinesischen Eltern in Kanada auf
und war noch nie in China.
Jetzt will er endlich
seine Wurzeln kennenlernen.
Es ist sehr wichtig, zu wissen,
woher meine Eltern stammen,
wie sie aufgewachsen sind.
Das ist etwas,
was mich sehr wunder nimmt.
Ich glaube, dass sie ganz anders
aufgewachsen sind als ich.
Das wird sicher
einfach sehr spannend,
was auf uns zukommen wird.
* Er lacht. *
Er kann Chinesisch.
- Ein bisschen.
Alicia wird
ohne Chinesisch aufwachsen.
Er spricht relativ gut Chinesisch.
Zu Hause
spricht er immer Chinesisch.
Alicia wird
nicht mehr Chinesisch sprechen,
wird nur noch
ein asiatisches Aussehen haben.
Weil sie somit noch weniger Kontakt
zu diesen chinesischen Wurzeln
haben wird, die sie aber besitzt,
dachten wir, ihr vielleicht
einmal erzählen zu können,
woher sie eigentlich stammt,
wo ihre Wurzeln liegen.
Momentan ist Yanceys Mutter
für ein paar Wochen Ferien in China.
Sie kann es kaum erwarten, dass
ihr Sohn und die Schwiegertochter
endlich auch kommen.
* Er spricht Kantonesisch. *
* Chinesische Klänge *
Grüezi miteinander.
- Grüezi. Danke.
Yanceys Eltern verliessen
China noch vor seiner Geburt
und bauten sich in Kanada
ein neues Leben auf.
Dort kam er zur Welt und wuchs
zusammen mit zwei Geschwistern auf.
Vor 18 Jahren
lernte Yancey Janine kennen,
die damals in Kanada
in den Ferien war.
Aus der Fernbeziehung
wurde eine grosse Liebe.
Darum zog Yancey vor gut zehn Jahren
zu Janine in die Schweiz.
Aber seine richtige Heimat
hat er bis heute nicht kennengelernt.
Ich wurde in Kanada geboren
und wuchs dort
umgeben von weissen Menschen auf.
Und wenn wir jetzt plötzlich
nach Hongkong fahren, nach China ...
Das wird schon ganz,
ganz anders als ...
Dazu muss ich etwas einschieben.
Als wir uns kennenlernten,
fragte ich ihn schon bald:
"Warst du noch nie in China?"
Er antwortete: "Nein."
Darauf fragte ich ihn:
"Aber du kommst doch aus China?"
"Und du warst noch nie in China?
Willst du nicht mal dorthin?"
Dann sagte er: "Nein."
Auf meine Frage: "Warum nicht?"
antwortete er:
"Dort sehen alle aus wie ich."
Komische Argumentation,
aber damals war er auch erst 16.
Heute wohnen die beiden
in Teufenthal.
Im Sommer 2018
kam ihre Tochter Alicia zur Welt.
Komm, komm. Wir zwei gehen.
Und was tun wir jetzt?
Yancey ist jeder Moment
mit seiner Familie extrem wichtig.
Er selber hatte früher
nicht viel von seinen Eltern.
Also ehrlich gesagt:
Als ich aufgewachsen bin,
habe ich nicht so wahnsinnig viel
Zeit mit meinen Eltern verbracht.
Sie hatten ihr eigenes Restaurant.
Das war echt heftig, wie viele Stun-
den sie in der Küche verbrachten.
Aber auch zum Einkaufen
verbrauchten sie viel Zeit.
Was haben wir hier?
Einen Marienkäfer.
Guten Morgen, Marienkäferchen.
Hast du gut geschlafen?
Seine Eltern gingen
hauptsächlich nach Kanada,
weil sie für ihre Kinder
eine bessere Zukunft wollten.
Das haben sie geschafft,
mussten dafür aber
mega hart arbeiten.
Ich nehme nicht an,
dass sie das so wollten.
Aber das musste so sein,
weil es sonst nicht gegangen wäre.
Wir haben jetzt natürlich nicht
eine so wahninnig enge Beziehung.
Natürlich werden sie
immer meine Eltern sein.
Ich sehe sie auch nur
ein paar Tage im Jahr.
Meinen Vater sehe ich vielleicht
einen Nachmittag im Jahr -
höchstens.
Mir reicht das normalerweise auch.
Alicia.
* Klicken *
Das wurde ein super Foto.
Lass uns essen, bevor uns
die Fliegen alles wegessen.
Die kleine Alicia macht
die weite Reise nach China nicht mit.
Sie bleibt
bei den Grosseltern in der Schweiz.
Für Janine und Yancey geht es
morgen los, zuerst nach Hongkong.
Prost, Schatz! Auf unsere Reise.
Auf unsere Reise!
Rochester an der Ostküste der USA.
Das war das Ziel von Susan
aus dem Kanton Glarus.
Nach Jahrzehnten hat sie
ihren Vater Donald wieder getroffen.
Susan war ein Baby,
als sich ihre Eltern getrennt hatten,
und ihre Mutter mit ihr
in die Schweiz zurückkehrte.
Zu ihrem Vater konnte sie
nie eine richtige Beziehung aufbauen.
Thanks, Dad.
Donald hat wieder geheiratet.
Susan hat deshalb
zwei Halbschwestern bekommen.
Der Kontakt zu ihrem Vater
brach in all diesen Jahren ab.
Aber die letzten Tage
brachten die beiden einander näher.
Heute, am Tag,
bevor Susan wieder zurückfliegt,
fahren Vater und Tochter
zu den Niagarafällen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Die beiden waren vor langer Zeit
schon einmal zusammen hier.
Es ist schön.
Vorher habe ich
heimlich hinter der Sonnenbrille
eine Freudenträne geweint.
Es ist mega eindrücklich.
Dass ich mit ihm - nach 1986 -
noch einmal hier sein darf,
dass ich das
mit ihm nochmals erleben darf,
das gibt mir ein grosses Kribbeln.
Seit sie erwachsen ist,
hat Susan noch nie so viel Zeit
mit ihrem Vater verbracht
wie in den letzten Tagen.
Ich habe ihn besser kennengelernt.
Ich habe viel erfahren,
wie er eigentlich ist.
Vieles wurde relativiert.
Mir wurde bewusst, wie sich der
spärliche Kontakt ausgewirkt hat.
Obwohl Donald
nicht viel Gefühl zeigen kann,
ist Susan erleichtert.
Zwischenzeitlich
war ich wirklich unsicher,
weil ich nicht gewusst habe,
ob ich in diesem Sinn
erwünscht bin oder nicht.
Ich bin weit weg, und er
mischt sich nicht in mein Leben.
So war es für ihn.
Das hat sehr viel
Interpretationsspielraum zugelassen.
Bei mir ging das so weit,
dass ich das persönlich nahm,
dass ich nie
ein erwünschtes Kind war.
Aber ich musste diesen Weg
selbst gehen.
Und ich würde es
wieder gleich machen.
Alles ist sehr erhellend.
Erst jetzt verstehe ich,
was für ein Typ er ist.
Die Reise in die fremde Heimat
brachte Susan Antworten,
die sie sehr lange gesucht hatte.
Endlich konnte sie
ihren Vater besser kennenlernen.
Gute Nachrichten in Zollikofen:
Sima kann in den Iran reisen.
Die Bewilligungen sind
nach langem Hin und Her endlich da.
So cool!
Ich verrate es dir:
Wir fahren. He, so toll!
Gut 8 Std. dauert die Reise
nach Täbris in den Norden Irans.
Aus dieser Stadt
stammt Simas Vater.
Um 2 Uhr nachts
landen Sima und ihr Mann Remo.
Trotzdem warten viele Verwandte
auf die zwei fremden
Familienmitglieder aus der Schweiz.
* Arabische Klänge *
Salam.
* Sie sprechen Persisch. *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
It's nice to see you.
So many people, oh my God.
Hello. Thank you. And you are?
My name is Sima.
- Mine too!
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ich bin völlig überfordert.
So viele Leute!
Ich dachte, es würden vier,
fünf Leute zum Flughafen kommen,
und jetzt ist
meine ganze Familie hier.
Es ist überwältigend.
Ich bin sprachlos.
Ich weiss gar nicht mehr,
wer wer ist.
Unglaublich!
Ich weiss gar nicht, wo Remo ist.
Es geht gleich weiter.
Salam.
Jetzt sind wir hier.
Es ist überwältigend, krass.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass so viele Leute hier sind.
Ich bin etwas überfordert.
Es ist ein Heimkommen,
wirklich ein Heimkommen.
Und es ist mir gleich vertraut,
ich fühle mich sofort wohl.
60 Verwandte
stehen schlussendlich am Flughafen.
Aus der Schweiz
meldet sich der Vater von Sima.
Er will wissen,
ob seine Tochter gut angekommen ist.
Alles gut!
Simas Vater, Majid,
fliegt in ein paar Tagen nach.
Zuerst soll seine Tochter ihre
fremde Heimat allein kennenlernen,
aber das muss bis morgen warten.
Mittlerweile ist es 3 Uhr morgens.
* Arabische Gitarrenklänge *
Wir haben es geschafft.
Wir sind hier.
Das ist Glück,
so etwas erleben zu dürfen.
Das erste Mal in ihrem Leben
ist Sima im Iran,
in dem Land, wo ihre Wurzeln liegen.
Es ist aber auch ein Land, das
bei vielen Leuten aus ihrem Umfeld
Angst und Unsicherheit auslöst.
Es hat mich sehr belastet, dass
von allen Seiten Bedenken kamen.
Meine Schwiegermutter hat mich bei
einer Familienzusammenkunft gefragt:
"Was sollen wir mit den Kindern tun,
wenn ihr nicht mehr zurückkehrt?"
Da war bei mir einfach Schluss.
Ich war nervlich am Ende:
"Was mache ich da eigentlich?"
Ich wusste gerade nicht mehr,
ob diese Reise
im Moment das Richtige ist.
Sima bereut ihre Entscheidung nicht.
Nach dem Empfang am Flughafen
fühlt sie sich gut aufgehoben.
Und das ist erst der Anfang
einer besonderen Reise.
* Asiatische Gitarrenklänge *
Auch Yancey und Janine
sind mittlerweile angekommen
im 10'000 km entfernten Hongkong.
Oh, mein Gott, diese Hitze!
Das ist ja wie im Backofen!
Es klebt schon alles.
Ihre Tochter Alicia
ist noch nicht einmal jährig,
darum ist sie zu Hause geblieben.
Yancey unternimmt
diese Reise in seine fremde Heimat
nicht nur für sich selber,
sondern auch für Alicia.
Mir ist wichtig,
dass ich auch noch
meine eigenen Wurzeln kennenlerne.
Ich war noch nie in China
oder im asiatischen Raum überhaupt.
Ich mache diese Reise auch,
damit ich Alicia später
etwas darüber mitteilen kann.
Für mich war seine Herkunft,
seine Familiengeschichte,
auch immer ein schwarzes Loch,
weil er wenig darüber weiss.
Ich weiss viel mehr
über meine Familie.
So können wir eine Lücke füllen -
auch für Alicia.
Bis vor 23 Jahren
war Hongkong eine britische Kolonie,
heute gehört Hongkong zu China.
Diese Metropole hat fast gleich
viele Einwohner wie die Schweiz.
Yancey und Janine wollen die Stadt
auf eigene Faust entdecken.
* Asiatische Orchesterklänge *
Und jetzt müssten wir dann
im Prinzip nicht diese,
sondern die nächste Strasse nehmen.
Allen anderen nach.
Genau, das ist die goldene Regel.
Komm, wir laufen
auf dieser Strassenseite,
weil es hier etwas Schatten hat.
- Ja.
Yancey, schau mal dort vorne links:
ein riesiges Gebäude.
Davon musst du ein Foto machen.
Hast du dein Handy im Hosensack?
Okay, ja.
Ich finde es spannend, dass hier die
Gerüste aus Bambus gebaut werden.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich mich getrauen würde,
in schwindelerregender Höhe auf
einem Bambusgerüst herumzuturnen.
Das Gebäude dort drüben
sieht lustig aus,
auf dem zuoberst ein Turm steht,
mit dem Victoria Peak
im Hintergrund.
Das Stadtzentrum wird
vom Victoria Harbour getrennt.
Ein Teil liegt
auf der Halbinsel Kowloon,
der andere auf Hongkong Island.
Schau, zwischen diesen Hochhäusern
liegt der Victoria Peak.
Jetzt musst du deinen Kopf ...
- Kleiner machen?
... etwas zur Seite halten.
Ja, so ist gut.
Wir haben im Sinn,
dort hinauf zu gehen:
auf Victoria Peak.
* Lautsprecherdurchsage
in Kantonesisch *
Verstehst du, was das heisst?
Einzelne Wörter kann ich erkennen,
aber es ergibt nicht wirklich Sinn.
Wahrscheinlich kenne ich
die wichtigen Wörter nicht:
Zahlen usw.
Yancey kann etwas Kantonesisch,
braucht die Sprache aber nur selten.
Mit dem Klima in der Stadt
haben alle zu kämpfen,
darum wollen Yancey und Janine
etwas in die Höhe
auf den Hausberg Hongkongs.
Wir erwarten eine kühle Brise.
Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig heiss.
Ich glaube, das kann man sich
gar nicht vorstellen.
Die Luftfeuchtigkeit
ist anstrengender als die Hitze.
An einem heissen Sommertag
liegt die Luftfeuchtigkeit bei 90 %.
Zum Glück fährt eine Bahn
auf den Gipfel des Victoria Peak.
Yancey entdeckt Hongkong als Tourist.
Er hat keine persönliche Beziehung
zu dieser Gegend,
aber es ist ein idealer Ort,
um das Abenteuer China zu beginnen.
Hongkong ist im Vergleich
zum restlichen Land sehr westlich.
Das sieht toll aus: Wahnsinn!
Hier können wir auch raus.
Hello. Two.
Two. The best viewpoint
is over there. Keep this ticket.
Okay. Thank you very much.
* Asiatische Klänge *
* Asiatische Orchesterklänge *
Wow!
Ganz, ganz schön!
Am anderen Ufer
sieht man das chinesische Festland.
wo Yanceys Vergangenheit
auf ihn wartet.
Das sieht toll aus.
- Das ist auch schön.
Von hier aus
sieht man die vielen Inseln.
Dieser Moment ist quasi
die Ruhe vor dem Sturm.
Wir werden in China
sehr viel Verwandtschaft sehen.
Und ...
Ich lasse mich überraschen,
was kommt.
Schon morgen will sich der 34-Jährige
auf die Suche
nach seinen Wurzeln machen.
Ich hoffe, dass Yancey
Antworten auf viele Fragen findet,
vielleicht auch Antworten findet
auf Fragen,
von denen er bisher noch
nicht weiss, dass es Fragen sind.
Dass er viel leeren Platz
füllen kann
mit Geschichten, mit Erfahrungen,
vielleicht auch mit Gerüchen
und Gerichten und Erlebnissen
aus seiner Heimat, die bis jetzt
sehr fern und fremd ist.
* Sanfte asiatische Orchesterklänge *
* Muezzin-Gesang *
40 °C kälter
und ein paar 1'000 km weiter westlich
liegt Täbris,
eine der grössten Städte im Iran.
* Lebhafte arabische Musik *
Zu den 1,5 Mio. Einwohnern
gehört auch Simas Verwandtschaft.
Ihr Vater wohnte in Täbris,
bevor er Ende der 60er-Jahre
in die Schweiz gekommen ist.
Seine fünf Geschwister und deren
Kinder sind im Iran geblieben.
Nach der ersten, kurzen Nacht
sind Sima und Remo heute eingeladen
zum Begrüssungsfest bei ihrem Onkel.
Ist es hier?
Geh du zuerst rein.
- Ich?
Salam.
- Salam.
Das ist Nefise, Simas Cousine.
Die beiden sahen sich das letzte Mal
vor 30 Jahren in der Schweiz.
* Sie spricht Persisch. *
Sima hadert noch etwas
mit dem Kopftuch.
Sie haben mich aufgefordert,
das Kopftuch auszuziehen.
Alle anderen Frauen tragen es,
aber sie fanden,
weil ich es nicht gewohnt sei
und bei mir zu Hause
auch kein Kopftuch trage,
müsse ich das hier auch nicht:
Ich bin hier wie zu Hause.
Kannst du das bitte halten.
Chocolate.
- Merci, merci.
Chocolate for you.
- Thank you.
Ich weiss gar nicht,
wem ich was geben soll.
Sokolat.
Swiss Chocolate.
- Thank you.
Auf dem Rundgang durch die Wohnung
zeigt Nefise Sima etwas aus
ihrer gemeinsamen Vergangenheit.
Eine uralte Zeichnung, die ich
als Achtjährige gemacht habe.
Die hat sie aufbewahrt.
Das ist unglaublich.
Ich hatte es damals
für meine Grossmutter gemalt,
die Malerin war.
Verrückt, dass sie die Zeichnung
aufbewahrt hat - unglaublich.
Ich habe immer an sie gedacht,
weil ich sie so gerne hatte.
Es war eine schöne Zeit,
als sie bei uns war.
Sie hat auch an mich gedacht.
Das war wirklich
eine wunderschöne Zeit,
die ich nie mehr vergessen werde.
Sie war damals für mich
so etwas wie eine grosse Schwester.
Diese Zeichnung ist nicht die
einzige Erinnerung, die auftaucht.
Das sind Aufnahmen,
als mein Vater nach viele Jahren
wieder zum ersten Mal
zurück in den Iran geflogen war.
Verrückt, wie viele Leute
ihn am Flughafen abgeholt hatten.
200 Leute hätten ihn abgeholt,
hat man mir erzählt.
Er zeigt tiefe Emotionen.
Sie haben seine Ankunft gefilmt,
weil es ihnen sehr wichtig war.
Es hat ihn damals sehr berührt,
das weiss ich noch,
obwohl es schon eine Weile her ist.
Alles weiss ich nicht mehr,
aber für ihn war das unglaublich.
Ich kann es nachfühlen, weil
es mir gestern ähnlich gegangen ist.
Ich kann meinen Vater
nicht weinen sehen.
Das berührt mich sehr.
* Lebhafte arabische Klänge *
Das Haus füllt sich mit dem
Empfangskomitee vom Flughafen,
das zum Essen kommt.
Sima wird noch einmal bewusst,
wie riesig ihre Verwandtschaft ist.
* Lebhafte arabische Musik *
Ich weiss immer noch nicht,
wer wer ist,
aber alle sind sehr nett.
Die Frauen haben
ein Festessen vorbereitet.
Traditionell wird in einer
so grossen Runde am Boden gegessen.
* Lebhafte arabische Musik *
Das ist für mich
eine unglaubliche Erfahrung.
Sitzt du so bequemer?
- Ja.
Mir schlafen die Füsse ein.
Grossartig.
Ich habe heute
sehr viele Eindrücke gewonnen
und so viel Liebe erfahren, echte
Familienliebe und Zusammenhalt.
Ich bin wirklich sehr, sehr müde,
weil es auch anstrengend ist.
Am Schluss weiss ich gar nicht mehr,
wen ich schon begrüsst habe.
Aber trotzdem war heute
ein fantastischer Tag.
Jetzt gehe ich glücklich ins Bett.
Aber das muss noch etwas warten.
Simas Verwandte wollen
die Gäste aus der Schweiz
nicht nur kulinarisch verwöhnen,
sondern auch mit iranischer Folklore.
* Arabische Flötenklänge *
Am nächsten Tag in China.
Yancey und seine Frau
fahren zum chinesischen Festland,
wo momentan
auch Yanceys Mutter Juchien weilt.
Ich freue mich, weil ich sie
nur einmal im Jahr sehe.
Es ist immer schön, sie zu treffen.
Ich kann kein Chinesisch.
Wenn die ganze Familie
Chinesisch spricht,
und meist ist das
sehr laut und relativ wild,
dann sitze ich in der Ecke
und denke:
Sie geniessen das Zusammensein.
Und esse noch etwas.
Das Ziel der beiden
ist Taishan in Südchina.
Aus dieser Gegend
stammt Yanceys Mutter.
Sie wohnt zwar
seit 40 Jahren in Kanada,
kommt aber einmal im Jahr
für ein paar Wochen nach China.
Yanceys Vater
arbeitet ständig in Kanada
und besucht seine Heimat
nicht so oft.
Jetzt ist alles nur noch Chinesisch
angeschrieben - ausser den Zahlen.
Ja.
In Hongkong war alles
noch englisch beschriftet.
Doch, die Strassennamen
sind noch in Englisch,
aber Läden usw. nicht mehr.
Das ist das echte China.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Alleine käme ich nirgends mehr hin.
- Ich auch nicht.
Yancey ist in Kanada aufgewachsen.
Für ihn ist China
ein komplett fremdes Land.
In diesem Quartier
wohnt seine Mutter,
wenn sie in China zu Besuch ist.
Es ist viel schöner, als ich
erwartet habe, ehrlich gesagt.
Was wir bis jetzt gesehen haben,
war akzeptabel,
aber hier ist es wirklich schön.
Sie hat immer erzählt,
dass es schön sei,
aber ich habe ihr
nie wirklich geglaubt.
So, schauen wir mal.
Juchien hat so geplant,
dass sie gleichzeitig mit ihrem Sohn
in China ist.
Sie will miterleben,
wie er sein Heimatland kennenlernt.
* Yancey und Janine lachen. *
Auch Yanceys Geschwister,
die in Kanada wohnen,
sind mit nach China gereist:
Toni und Mailin.
Oh my God!
* Sie sprechen auf Englisch
durcheinander. *
Why?
Es ist ein seltsames Gefühl,
weil ich niemals gedacht hätte,
dass ich Yanceys Familie
in China sehen würde.
Ich auch nicht.
Es ist wirklich ...
Ja, ich bin wirklich
positiv überrascht.
Was ist mit meinen Haaren?
Janine hat zwar noch nichts gesagt,
aber ich bin positiv überrascht.
Seit Yancey vor mehr als zehn Jahren
in die Schweiz ausgewandert ist,
sieht sich die Familie
nur noch einmal im Jahr.
* Asiatische Lautenklänge *
* Feierlicher, arabischer Gesang *
Zurück im Iran.
Nach dem turbulenten Empfang
in Täbris
wollen Sima und Remo zwei, drei Tage
allein unterwegs sein.
Mit ihm kann ich jetzt auch einmal
über meine Gefühle sprechen,
die ich hier empfinde,
weil ich auch
etwas Zeit für mich habe.
Remo wurde an diesen ersten Tagen
im Iran einiges klar.
Jetzt weiss ich,
wieso sie zu Hause so ist.
Es hat sehr viele Parallelen.
Oft habe ich mich gefragt:
"Wieso ist mein Schwiegervater so?"
"Wieso will er uns ständig sehen?"
"Wieso ist er
ein so extremer Familienmensch?"
Und hier ist all das hochgekommen.
Aber ich finde schön
und verstehe es jetzt viel besser.
Die zwei sind in Isfahan
und wollen sich die
Scheich-Lotfulla-Moschee ansehen,
die im 16. Jh.
für die Königsfamilie erbaut wurde.
Die Moschee ist bekannt
für ihre einzigartige Akustik.
Wow!
- Wahnsinn!
Es hallt stark.
- Es ist mega schön.
Wenn du singen würdest,
gäbe es einen schönen Klang.
Ich kann leider nicht singen.
Nein, lass es besser bleiben.
In einer Moschee
darf man nicht singen.
* Sie sagen im Duett:
"Isfahan". *
* Langer Nachhall *
* Sie lachen. *
Die majestätische 33-Bogen-Brücke
ist ein architektonisches Meisterwerk
und ein Wahrzeichen der Stadt.
* Arabische Gitarrenklänge *
Sima und Remo
geniessen die Zweisamkeit.
Ich fühle mich wie vor elf Jahren,
als wir uns kennengelernt haben.
Es ist hier echt romantisch.
Das ist ein schöner Moment,
der zu den zwei Tagen passt,
die wir hier geniessen.
Es ist wirklich super.
Obwohl sich die zwei
im Iran sehr willkommen fühlen,
möchte Sima nicht hier leben.
Das Kopftuch geht mir
ziemlich auf den Senkel.
Ich brauche die Freiheit,
die ich von zu Hause her kenne,
dass ich mich kleiden kann,
wie ich will.
* Asiatische Flötenklänge *
Die ganze Familie ist unterwegs.
Endlich kann Juchien Yancey
ihre Heimatstadt Taishan zeigen.
Die zwei waren
noch nie zusammen hier.
Aber bevor es
mit der Sightseeing Tour losgeht,
müssen sie
noch etwas Wichtiges erledigen.
Das alles gehört
zu einem uralten Ritual.
Wow!
* Sie lachen. *
* Sie sprechen durcheinander
auf Kantonesisch. *
Weil ich das noch nie gemacht habe,
muss ich
die letzten 30 Jahre aufholen.
Deshalb muss ich so viel opfern,
damit das richtiggestellt wird.
So viele Jahre ohne Opfergaben
läppern sich zusammen.
Yancey muss
seinen Vorfahren im Jenseits
10 Mio. Yen in Falschgeld bezahlen.
Ich habe einfach keine Ahnung,
was sie sagen.
Unterdessen vor dem Laden - steht
Janine plötzlich im Mittelpunkt.
Ich glaube,
ich bin gerade die Attraktion,
weil ich Europäerin bin.
Jemand wagte,
mich um ein Foto zu bitten -
und jetzt ist der Bann gebrochen:
Jetzt kommen alle.
Das war ziemlich intensiv.
Plötzlich versammelten sich
etwa 60 Personen,
die alle ein Foto
mit Janine machen wollten.
Das nächste Mal steht zur Abwechslung
Yancey im Mittelpunkt.
Ich bin so wahnsinnig froh,
dass wir das erlebt haben.
Diese Erlebnisse werden
für immer in unseren Herzen bleiben.
Sima taucht
in die iranische Kultur ein.
Wahnsinnig, die vielen Farben hier.
Und es riecht fein nach Gewürzen,
die ich von meinem Vater kenne.
Und am Schluss der Reise
trifft sie ihren Vater.
Ich fühle, dass dies ein gross-
artiger Moment in meinem Leben ist.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Roger Schmid - 2020